um you can't you can't uh you know what
people say we incentivize performance
you can't incentivize results like you
can't do that you can only incentivize
the behavior that'll achieve a certain
result um and if it's only about the
short term then guess what you're going
to drive a behavior that drives short
term and so in your case what are the
behaviors that you're recognizing and
rewarding and so if people are getting
bonused only for hitting numbers
and they're not getting bonus for how
they do business then you're going to
incentivize a certain behavior so i'll
give you an example
so young in my career i worked at an ad
agency and i was the junior dog's buddy
to the junior dogs buddy
and
it was traditional for a big new
business pitch that the senior folks
would run the pitch
well it happened to be around christmas
time and all the senior folks went on
vacation and so me and one other junior
person who were left behind because we
didn't go on vacation were told to
prepare the war room which basically
means take a conference room and fill it
up with all the research well that took
a few hours right but we still had a
week
and so she and i
decided to write the whole pitch we went
through all the research and we came up
with a strategy and we wrote the pitch
all the senior leaders came back we
presented our work and they actually
used our strategy
in this new business pitch
and we lost the pitch we didn't win
and i got a huge promotion
my boss actually moved me up two levels
inside the company
because he wasn't rewarding my
performance he was awarding and
rewarding my initiative
by by giving me a promotion for taking
the risk to do the extra work guess what
i did after that took more risks and did
more work even if it meant
winning or losing didn't become the
primary factor for me it was the
initiative that but that wasn't because
of me and my and my innate anything
that's because that's the behavior my
boss wanted from me
and so i think what happens when we get
big is we be we do become too obsessed
with the result and we don't consider
the behavior there are some brilliant
people making big decisions
who may have missed the number
or may have
missed the goal
but we gave them nothing
which sends a subconscious message to
the rest of the company which is if you
hit your numbers you'll do well here if
you don't hate your numbers we don't
care how you do it as long as you know
so you get the point so i think i think
it happens big companies need to go back
and reevaluate how they recognize and
reward
and what if you want if you want risk
taking then recognize the people taking
risks even when they fail it goes back
to that sometimes it's just incredibly
positive feedback
publicly yeah
even better right public you give you
give positive feedback publicly and you
criticize privately right you don't you
don't take somebody at a task in front
of a conference room and you don't do it
right um
but publicly i'd like to point out and
say thank you to stacy stacy that's the
kind of stuff we want to see at this
company it didn't work out this time but
keep doing that because that's what we
need here
well that's a good thing
so
if you just send her a nice email and
say great job it's it's going to have
little to no effect